the story out of oregon a group of
oregon high school and middle middle
school students
these young girls
decided that they were going to protest
sexualization
by taking off their clothes at school
and just wearing their bras
this is a real story it's not not the
onion it's not the babylon bee
at southridge high school in beaverton
school district students came to school
in lace bras that revealed everything
did not leave very much to the
imagination lingerie bottoms according
to one parent
and they did this they wrote actually
some protest slogans on their bodies and
some of their clothing that
that said rape culture or educate your
boys or my body
or my clothing choice my body my
clothing choice
i don't know what
young man at this high school came up
with this idea but he is a genius he is
a devilish clever man to convince the
women
that they were going to protest
sexualization
by taking all their clothes off and
parading around for the boys that's
that is like protesting obesity by
eating a bunch of donuts that is like
protesting lung disease by just
slurping up cigarettes not just chain
smoking non-stop
but this there is a kind of logic to it
just like there's a kind of logic to
defund the police and abolish prisons if
you think america is hopelessly unjust
then obviously you've got to dismantle
the system of laws well it's the same
thing here
this is the logical consequence of this
liberal conception of
of the individual being able to do
whatever the individual wants based
purely on the individual's will
if i want to be a woman then i really am
a woman and my will will transform
reality
if i want to
pursue whatever desire i want then i can
do that and you have no right to stop me
from doing that
well this is the logical conclusion of
that
the girls are saying i don't want
boys to look on me with lust
okay and i don't i don't want to have to
watch where i walk at night i don't i
don't want to have to worry about
walking down a dark alley wearing a
miniskirt in the middle of the night in
the bad section of town i shouldn't have
to worry about that i'm the victim stop
victim blaming me just teach boys not to
rape
just teach boys not to look lustfully on
women well sure yeah there are laws
against rape right there of course
that's good we like that the law is an
instructor the law is but
you will never
never
stop boys
from getting a thrill out of seeing
naked ladies you're j it just can't
happen no matter how much you desire
that no matter how intransigent you are
and and
and
obstinate you are about your rights and
your will
you will never convince boys not to
think that naked ladies are cute and hot
you will it can't happen
well just teach boys not no you're what
you are doing
is denying reality and making the
problem worse
if you are protesting sexualization by
prancing around in your bras
you are not go it just won't help you're
making when we deny reality we make
problems worse
though you do wonder with these high
school sort of protests how much of it
is just
you know the more things change the more
things remain the same how much of this
is just
the girls putting on a show for the boys
and how much of this is the boys
you know trying to flirt with the girls
you wonder these things whatever it is
it's not an effective political protest
and whatever whatever dudes whatever
creepy dudes convince the girls to do
this stop it that's not that's not nice
to do hey i'm glad you like that clip
but hold
up ring that bell please
that would be great i'd appreciate it
get the notifications you won't miss an
episode and if
some of our friends
do have you miss an episode in the big
tech world head on over to apple podcast
spot if i stitch your google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you